List of things that men love hearing on.
You are such an amazing father.
This only applies if he's a dad.
Tell him what a great job he's doing at raising them.
The role of a father is undoubtedly the most important in his life.
Hearing that will make his day 10.
You handle challenging situations with such ease.
Two types of people in this world.
Those who get frustrated at any problem that arises.
And those who stay cool, calm and collected.
If your man can stay rational with logic and challenging situations,
appreciate him for this. There's not a thing I would change about you
physically and mentally and emotionally.
If you have a Jackpot of a husband partner,
make sure that he knows this.
I guarantee you, all men love hearing these things. Try it out.